ja so ist es denn wenn man darüber redet
was die menschen derzeit am meisten
bewegt dann ist es natürlich im moment
die inflation dann ist es die
wirtschaftliche lage in unserem land wir
haben die höchste inflation seit 40
jahren und das spüren die bürger das
stören sie an der tankstelle der spüren
sie im supermarkt und langfristig hat
das natürlich auch folgen für die
altersvorsorge für die ganze vermögens
ordnung in unserem land und deswegen ist
es auch eines der schwerpunktthemen dass
wir in dieser woche im deutschen
bundestag besprechen und die ampel hat
dafür jetzt ihre großen vorschläge
vorgelegt und da muss man sagen sie
gehen nicht weit genug sondern sie
setzen an der falschen stelle an die
grünen haben mal versprochen
bürgerenergie geld für alle daraus ist
jetzt geworden ein in eine energie
pauschale für weniger für wenige schüler
den studenten gehen leer aus rentner
gehen leer aus das ist ein system das im
moment nicht zusammenpasst und die ampel
hat mit dem neuen euro ticket und
anderen projekten
individuelles klein klein gemacht aber
die großen themen die werden nicht
angepackt die kalte progression die
steuerbelastung das ist im moment das
thema wir brauchen einen
inflationsschutz schirm der muss jetzt
aufgespannt werden und das kleinklein
der ampel geht da einfach nicht weiter
und wenn ich da eigentlich nur anknüpfen
dürfte der abend hat völlig recht die
inflation ist das größte änderung mittel
vor allem für arme leute ja das ist
einfach des lng und sozial ohne ändern
muss etwas dagegen tun für mich noch aus
dem parteipolitischen geplänkel
raushalten würde aber auch mal sagen was
wir auch wissen müssen wir müssen
eigentlich zur bekämpfung der inflation
bei der europäischen zentralbank eine
ansteigende zinsen sollten diese
steigenden zinsen führen und wiederum zu
einer zahlungsunfähigkeit von
griechenland frankreich und italien und
deswegen kann die europäische
zentralbank das momentan nicht anheben
das ist der hintergrund der debatte
deswegen weiß ich nicht ob wir klug
beraten zudem deutschland einzelgänger
zu machen weil wir dann am ende wiederum
indirekt skeptisch schaut nach korruptes
zu viel aber schlecht aufgestellte
staatshaushalt den anderen europäischen
union finanziert weil wir müssen das
eine tun ohne das andere zu lassen und
natürlich ist diese ezb überlagerung für
uns ein massives problem ich glaube sie
haben auch völlig recht wenn sie die
politischen motive der ezb ein stück
weit da auch mit ansprechen natürlich
respektieren wir die geldpolitische
unabhängigkeit der ezb bei zur wahrheit
gehört und das sehen wir ja auch seit
vielen jahren zunehmend das natürlich an
mancher stelle da auch
wirtschaftspolitik mit gemacht wird das
bundesverfassungsgericht lang darauf
hingewiesen und natürlich hängt viel
unserer inflation auch in europa im
moment am handeln der ezb aber ich sage
auch der verweis auf die ezb entbindet
uns nicht von der verpflichtung dass wir
auch am steuerrecht was machen weil wir
diskutieren jetzt über 12 euro
mindestlohn und sie müssen wissen das
finde ich richtig gerade in der
aktuellen inflationsrate dass der lohn
12 euro im durchschnitt beträgt
staatlicher eingriff jetzt mal ein
angestellt aber mit 12 euro mindestlohn
landet jetzt der arbeitnehmer der diesen
mindestlohn besteht schon im
steuerprogression stativ das ist absurd
das können sie keinem erklären gerade
die kleinen und mittleren einkommen sind
die die im moment die last tragen und
der staat verdient durch die erhöhten
mehrwertsteuer einnahmen und diese
mehreinnahmen die wir im moment haben an
der stelle insgesamt haben wir natürlich
große lasten zu schultern aber der
inflations mehr gewinnen aus
mehrwertsteuer und anderen er muss
direkt in die entlastung fließen und das
muss der anspruch sein das macht die
ampel im moment ja ich hätte hier noch
eine ergänzung erst einmal freue ich
mich sehr in diesem zusammenhang was sie
gesagt haben und connery das hat er eine
domino wirkung hin gesamte eu und wir
wissen wenn wir ins trudeln kommen mit
unserer währung beispielsweise ist in
griechenland das licht sehr schnell
wieder aus denn wir garantieren dass ja
alles das muss man einfach sehen und wie
das geleistet werden soll kann er aus
meiner sicht nur sagen wir müssen alle
ausgaben alle aufgaben aufgaben kritiker
unterziehen und müssen die
leistungsträger stärken und das
bildungssystem
wir können heute keine genügend
ausbildungsplätze zu sagen wir mal
ausbildungsplatz not heute haben wir
überschuss wir sind nicht in der lage
aufgrund der niedrigen
bildungsvoraussetzungen die unsere
schulen produzieren die leute
unterzubringen wir haben
fachkräftemangel ich freue mich über
jeden ukraine wer weiß mehr mit zehn
jahren ich habe drei kinder in meinem
haus untergebracht aus der ukraine da
ist ein zehnjähriger schüler da geht in
die vierte klasse der kästner schule in
berlin er erklärt dem lehrer den laptop
zehn jahre alt aus der ukraine kommen
das ist der standort deutschland zu
tragen war auf nein lassen
akademiker nicht im taxi sitzen oder
sie sind ja ordentlich ich bin der
meinung es muss eine totale
aufgabenkritik auch an universitäten her
wir haben einen bauch angefressen haben
unnützen dingen die ihr mittels
mitschleppen wenn wir das nicht tun und
die masse sagt ab dann kann ich sagen
gute nacht demokratische entwicklung sei
daher auch möglich ist zeigt an der
rechten seite und auf der anderen seite
haben sich auch die hände und wir
im alltag
noch nicht so sehr aber das wird schon
kommen und ich habe patienten die spüren
sehr ich denke dass wir schon auch
irgendwo an den punkt heran kommen wo
wir uns überlegen müssen dass vieles von
den problemen die wir heute haben
aufgrund von irrationalität entstanden
ist dass wir als gesellschaft nicht mehr
rational auflösungen streiten sondern
emotionale glaubenssätze als maßstab
setzen jeder der kritisiert ist dann ein
neuer klimaleugner als nazi und so
weiter wir haben bei der energiepolitik
wir haben bei vielen anderen bereichen
auch bei gesundheit ist inzwischen so
ein moralismus drin und das habe ich
finde ich auch dass das ist bei kerner
ja auch das dominierende von anfang an
gewesen dass das kostet wahnsinnig viel
geld das sieht man jetzt hört man bei
den energie geschichte was gerade
passiert die kosten von corona ist sind
immens die hat übrigens ein beamter des
bundesinnenministeriums ganz früh
berichtet er wurde als belohnung jetzt
vom dienst entfernt und armut macht
krank das wissen wir und und wir müssen
zurückkehren zu einer zu einer
diskussion die wirklich rationalist das
sagt jemand der die ganze zeit eher
rational argumentieren
haben eine spricht sie haben eine
sprache ich bin dann uhr stellt sie
haben eine sprache die finde ich
wirklich bemerkenswert sie haben ja auch
sie haben terroristen die leute genannt
sie haben sie doch am klappen doch sie
haben gesagt
entsorger das ende der welt